your daddy gave me this no I'm gonna
give it to you
it's very special we'd love to know what
you think of the rumors Michelle
Rodriguez because apparently you used to
date your Fast & Furious co-star there
have been lots of reports about your
love life over the years how many of
those romance rumors are true from Zac
Efron to Cara Delevingne the list of
famous people you've reportedly dated
goes on and on we're getting revved up
for the release of fast and furious 9 in
May 20-22 help with the weight we're
delving into the real-life partners of
the cast
keep watching to discover all about John
Cena's new love interest and how his
famous ex has moved on in a major way
life sometimes is tough but it is life
and it goes on Michelle Rodriguez's
character Letty Ortiz might be married
to Vin Diesel's character in Fast and
Furious but they're not involved
romantically in real life well not
anymore
rumors swirled in 2001 that the couple
was dating off screen after reportedly
falling for each other on set but even
if that were true nothing came of it
Michelle openly identifies with bisexual
and has been linked to various people
over the years she's reportedly been
involved with Colin Farrell
Oliver Martinez Lenny Kravitz her
BloodRayne co-star Christina Logan and
Zac Efron in 2018 she was linked to 22
year old modeled Jordan Barrett after he
shared an Instagram story of them
vacationing in Sardinia
her most recent high-profile
relationship however was with English
model cara delevingne in 2014 Michelle
reportedly said that it was going really
well with the cool Brits as of 2020
however Michelle isn't in a confirmed
relationship a luxury you can't live
without love that's a luxury yes
Vin Diesel is a secretive man when it
comes to his private life but we do know
that the actor who plays Dominic Toretto
is in a long-term relationship with
Mexican model
Paloma Jimenez they met in 2007 and have
been together ever since then was born
in 1967 and Paloma was born in 1983 so
there's a 16-year age gap between them
that means that when they became parents
in April 2008 VIN was 40 years old and
Paloma was 24 the couple now has three
children together their first daughter
Hania Riley was born in April 2008 their
son Vincent Sinclair was born in 22 and
then their daughter Pauline was born in
March 2015
she's named in honor of Vince close
friend and Fast & Furious co-star Paul
Walker who passed away in November of
2013 then is the Godfather of Paul's
daughter meadow Walker Charlize Theron
stars as cypher in the Fast & Furious
franchise and her love life is as much a
secret code as her character's name no
family no obligations in January 2020
rumors were swirling that Charlize was
dating Channing Tatum but just as the
story came out Channing's seemed to
confirm that his romance with British
singer Jessie J was back on that puts
that theory to bed so what is going on
in Charlize his love life well back in
April 2019 the actor told Entertainment
Tonight that she'd been single for five
years she described her status as
shockingly available and she added that
somebody just needed to step up and ask
her out on a date she previously dated
Stuart Townsend they met on the set of
the 2002 film trapped after they split
in 2010 Charlize started dating Sean
Penn they announced their engagement in
2014 but split in 2015 Charlize has two
daughters Jackson and August Jackson who
she adopted in 2012 was born Mel but has
identified as a girl since she was three
where is he son Kang is back as Han Liu
for a movie number nine impressive I
know yes that's how the Fast & Furious
franchise works you never know what
surprises they're going to throw your
way so does Sun fall into the category
of fast and furious actors who are
happily married indeed he does Tseng is
married to Miki him the couple tied the
knot on July 8 2014 in a small private
ceremony with just close friends and
family presents sung was 42 years old
when they went you're probably
interested to know if songs wife is in
the movie business too but while she is
not an actor or a musician or a model
she does work in a fancy industry the
designer fashion industry to be precise
she's a general manager at Prada sung
and Miki met in Koreatown karaoke song
was singing when doves cry it sounds
like it wasn't a perfect rendition and
Miki reportedly teased her future
husband about his singing voice English
actor Natalie Emmanuel plays computer
hacker Ramsay natalie is best known for
playing Masson de Denari Targaryens
right hands woman in Game of Thrones of
my queen because I want to serve my
queen and fans were seriously shipping
miss Andy and grey worm who was played
by Jacob Anderson so much so that many
fans assumed that the actors were in a
relationship in real life but is Natalie
really dating Jacob the answer is no in
real life Natalie is dating a fellow
actor but she's not a part of the game
of Thrones alumni her Vaes name is Alex
Lynn if accan and he's best known for
his roles in homeland and Troy fall of
the city although they don't speak about
their relationship publicly they have
been spotted out together since 2018
they've also worked together as
producers on the short film which
premiered at the 2018 Cannes Film
Festival and Natalie made an emotional
speech about Alex and her mom at her
30th birthday party in March 2019
yeah
is a superwoman Jordana Brewster plays
Mia Toretto in Fast and Furious crappy
yesterday her characters in a
relationship and has two young children
and in real life Jordana is in a
relationship and also has two kids the
actor lives in Los Angeles with her
husband Andrew form the couple met when
they were both working on the 2006 movie
the Texas Chainsaw Massacre the
beginning Jordana was acting in Andrew
was producing their whirlwind romance
moved fast and they announced their
engagement on November 4th of the same
year just one month after the film was
released keeping with the fast timeline
the couple tied the knot just six months
later they married on May 6 2007 in a
private ceremony in the Bahamas the
couple welcomed their first child
julianne on september 10th 2013 their
second son Rowan was born on June 9th
2016 Jordana has spoken about how she
needed to use a gestational surrogate
for both of her sons Chris Ludacris
bridges plays Judge Parker in the
franchise you ain't stealing his cards
and in real life he's happily married to
you doc see she moved to the u.s. from
West Africa and studied at the
University of Miami to become a doctor
she graduated with both bachelor's and
master's degrees although she doesn't
currently practice the couple started
dating in 2009 and got married at
Christmastime in 2014 keeping the good
times coming they welcomed their
daughter cadence in June 2015
you doxy shared a photo on Instagram of
the welcome home flowers that Ludacris's
Fast & Furious co-star Vin Diesel sent
but it hasn't all been plain sailing for
the couple when Ludacris conceived a
daughter with Tameka fuller there was
speculation about the status of his
relationship with you doxy at the time
but whatever difficulties the couple
faced they put them behind them in
January 2015 just a month after they Wed
Ludacris was granted full custody of his
13 month old daughter with Tameka
kybella their blended family includes
Ludacris's daughter karma who
born in 2001 and in January 2020
Ludacris revealed he had become a
citizen of U dachsies home country Gabon
unfortunately Tyrese Gibson family life
isn't quite as settled as his co-stars
the actor who plays Roman Pearce has
been involved in a custody battle with
his ex-wife for many years Tyrese and
his ex Norma welcomed their daughter in
2007 but divorced in 2009 after less
than a year of marriage they had been
together for eight years and they're
still involved in a conflict over
custody of their 12 year old daughter
Shayla after all these years Tyrese
revealed in an interview with Wendy
Williams in October 2019 that even
though you've been with someone for a
long time when you finally get married
you realize that it was not the right
thing to do his current love life is
positive though the actor remarried on
Valentine's Day in 2017
Tyrese weds social workers Samantha Lee
and they welcomed their daughter
seraya on October 1st 2018 don't think
that's my job Helen Mirren stars as
Magdalene Shaw in Fast and Furious 9 and
the English actress who is in her 70s
has been in a relationship with the same
partner for many years she got together
with the American director Taylor
Hackford after they met on the set of
the 1985 film white knights Colin
revealed in the 2016 interview that she
very consciously chose her work over her
relationships right up to the time she
met Taylor when she was 38 although
she'd previously felt she never wanted
to Wed she revealed they got married in
the end because they realized they were
going to be together forever
what's your secret spending a lot of
time apart she said that the great thing
about finding a partnership later on in
life is that you recognized the
partnership level as much as the love
and the lust of it the couple got
married on New Year's Eve in 1997 it was
Taylor's third marriage
helen is stepmom to tailors to children
she said that she has no maternal
instinct whatsoever although she's so
happy she doesn't have children the
actor admitted that she does love
children and she has great pleasure
being involved with her husband's
children due to the cast for the ninth
installment of the franchise
John Cena plays Jacob Toretto he's Dom's
brother and is a major player in the new
movie as Dwayne the rock Johnson isn't
starring in the latest installment John
fills that wrestler void but what about
his personal life he most famously dated
his fellow WWE wrestling star Nikki
Bella they were together for six years
but broke off their engagement in April
2018 then in January 2020 Nikki
announced she was engaged to her Dancing
with the Stars partner artemchik Vinson
Nikki isn't the only one to have moved
on as Don is also in a new relationship
his current partner is Shay Shari Azadi
they made the red carpet debut as a
couple for the New York premiere of
playing with fire although she's keeping
their relationship on the down-low John
did open up to say with great confidence
that he's extremely happy with his
current love life I'm still here I'm
still going so I choose to go let us
know which cast member is your favorite
in the comments please give us a big
thumbs up and remember to hit that
subscribe button to be the first to
watch our latest videos thanks for
watching the things